back in the good old days if you were a
politician doesn't really matter what
side you were on and you wanted to make
you know a little extra side money
thanks to the powerful position you're
in it was pretty simple you take bribes
and stuff the nineteen thousand dollars
into your freezer you coincidentally buy
shares of certain companies at just the
right time thanks to some insider
information you got or you just cut to
the chase and make it as easy for your
customers as possible like former
congressman Duke Cunningham did with
this innovative bribe menu one is
sixteen million dollar defense contracts
awesome that would be a hundred forty
thousand dollars and a luxury yacht what
you need a bigger contract that would be
an extra fifty thousand dollars for each
additional $1,000,000 in contract value
but today we'll only 17% of people
actually trusting the government to do
the right thing these crude methods of
directly taking bribes just don't work
anymore the people are just witch
hunting for corrupt politicians to
figuratively hang on
so taking direct bribes is the
equivalent of painting a target on the
back of your head and stepping on the
firing line it's suicide and pretty
stupid are you trying to solicit a bribe
from me who cares about a few measly
thousand dollars you're a selfless
public servant after all you deserve
more we need a new way to take bribes a
new way to get insider deals to leverage
our political position for our own
personal gain without alerting the
public and directly breaking any laws we
need to learn how to best be corrupt and
get away with
[Music]
since you're gonna learn how to make all
this newfound money you might as well
grow in that money using a free trading
platform like weeble especially with the
worst market drop in like 30 years I
just recently happened start training
for free and get two free stocks where
you open an account and deposit any
amount with the link below as a
politician you're in the business of
selling influence to those looking to
buy political favors exceptions insider
deals and your customers whether that be
a local company or foreign corporation
or government pays in the form of bribes
and the reason why all those traditional
methods we went over don't work anymore
is that even though the public is pretty
oblivious most of the time let's be
honest after a while the public does
eventually catch on to things and once
they did catch on to these schemes they
crack down and put together pesky
disclosure laws for politicians that
make our lives a lot more difficult like
having to disclose our income assets and
financial transactions for ourselves and
our spouse or in other words it's now
illegal to hide any big payday that
directly comes our way and even if the
money you're getting is legal it's
probably best to avoid any suspicious
transactions at all cost because why
draw attention to yourself if the public
is already suspicious of you but fear
not because there's a very simple
solution to this that does require more
work but it's absolutely worth it
because instead of pathetically stuffing
90,000 dollars into your freezer we're
able to move hundreds of millions of
dollars at a time sometimes even
billions of dollars without ever
alerting the public much or less giving
them a way to fight back and to do this
we just need to borrow a simple concept
from the business world called
offshoring as the economy becomes more
and more global companies use offshoring
to maximize their profits some
offshoring is completely legitimate and
just a no-brainer business move but some
companies do it to obscure their
transactions to hide who or what they're
doing business with that is how we're
gonna solve this disclosure problem by
offshoring our corruption even though us
and our spouse are required to disclose
any big paydays we get we don't have to
disclose anything if our adult kids or
close friends got a convenient deal so
what do we do instead of us
the question will deal in getting our
hands dirty we moved the deal and the
people involved half the country to
places where there are far less
disclosure laws instead of us doing the
deal it's our kids or close friends
doing the deal not only is this better
for us but the people buying our
influence also appreciate being out of
the limelight and the great thing is
even if the public catches one of this
since there's no law forcing us disclose
anything we're covered we have an added
layer of legal protection or in other
words what we're doing is called
corruption by proxy where we get the
same results using our position of power
for personal gain without any of the
downsides of taking a direct bribe
because we have a middleman brokering
the deal for us close friends or family
says no money touches our accounts were
in the clear now you may be thinking to
yourself but Jake what is the point of
all this if it's really your friends or
family getting rich and not you that's
the point when the plebs see this they
can't pin it on you that's the beauty of
it we're in the game of building the
family and part of leaving a legacy
after all these are your kids and close
friends were talking about here even
though the money may be under their name
and accounts you got them in on the
scheme whatever split you agreed upon is
as good as yours you're old and you're
gonna die and leave your money to your
kids anyways why not just skip all that
nonsense and avoid incriminating
yourself by funneling the money directly
to your kids or close friends
[Music]
throughout human history no matter what
culture you looked at using arranged
marriages as a tool to get access to
powerful people has been the norm if my
son marries your daughter you're
probably gonna be more likely to do
business with me and pass favors all on
my way now today arranged marriages
don't really mix well with our Western
culture so instead of arranging our kids
to be married to each other they go into
business with each other and still get
all the same benefits and don't worry no
matter if you're right left it's all the
same just take a look at what the sons a
former Vice President Joe Biden a former
Senator John Kerry did when they were
both in office their sons Hunter and
Christopher found at an international
private equity firm called Rosemont
Seneca Partners and as Joe Biden was
carrying out important foreign relation
missions in China Hunter's company also
closed some pretty sweet deals with the
Chinese government at the same time
coincidentally of course in 2013 as the
tensions in East China Sea were rising
with China making some very aggressive
territorial claims China today scrambled
war planes over disputed islands that
are claimed by both China and Japan and
acetone in Beijing reports tensions are
rising fast Joe Biden and his son hunter
went to visit China to try to calm
things down after a mere ten days passes
hunter closed a 1.5 billion dollar deal
what the Chinese government run Bank of
China where the Chinese government was
literally funding a business that was
co-owned by some of America's most
powerful decision-makers a deal that no
other Western firms were much longer
track records and much more experienced
than Rosemont Seneca were able to
accomplish with the Chinese at the time
but since China rld had a lot to gain by
getting closer to the vice president of
the US why not throw a bone to his son
China's influence will grow and Joe
Biden's family's wealth will get bigger
without Joe running into any of the
legal troubles if he were the one to get
the deal this led to many other similar
deals that were equally as lucrative but
what if you're just a small-time
politician and you're not at the
prestigious level of vice-president of
the US well don't worry because this
still works even at the city level
[Music]
Chicago has long been considered one of
the most tainted cities in the u.s. even
the Chicago Tribune openly wondered if
the city was now the most corrupt city
in America and from 1955 all the way up
to 2011 Chicago's mayor position was
ruled by the same family the dailies and
they wore experts at this game of
corruption by proxy for example there
was a major restaurant that had dailies
friends and neighbors as investors the
very fancy Park Grill and when it came
out that the restaurant was receiving
free gas water and garbage collection
that costed the city five million
dollars per year mayor Daly was
subpoenaed and questioned about it where
he answered I don't recall a hundred and
thirty nine times much like other
sophisticated politicians mayor Daly
also uses family for inside reduce to
avoid being detected in 2003 his son
Patrick and his nephew RJ bought five
percent ownership into the local
municipal sewer service for sixty five
thousand dollars this company worked for
the city of Chicago already in the
following year they got a four million
dollar no big contract extension
coincidentally of course now could they
have gotten that four million dollar
extension because they were just doing
such a great job for the city yes but
then in 2011 the company's president was
charged with three counts of fraud the
company was shut down and unsurprisingly
the nephew and son weren't charged as a
local politician you're not limited to
using these tactics with local companies
either foreign companies love doing
business with lucrative big cities in
Chicago the city has practically
complete control over taxi companies as
the Chicago sun-times puts it in Chicago
city officials determine the number of
cabs who can operate them who can own
them who can drive them and how much
riders paid the right in limb so it's a
pretty tough business to get into with a
very high barrier for entry and extreme
regulations not for Mayor Daley's
friends low in 2001 Daley son Patrick
became friends with a Russian
businessman named Simon Garber Garber
also wanted to get into the taxi
business in Chicago and with the public
endorsement of Mayor Daley himself
within a few years the adventure grew to
Chicago's largest taxi cab business
while his competitors
continued to suffer now you maybe sing
but Jake how do you know for sure that
these people are corrupt and it really
just wasn't a coincidence you're right I
can't we are in the speculation zone if
I'm wrong then good for them and their
families businesses but if I'm right
then it just shows the potential of what
we're talking about here the Biden
family and the Daley family are just two
examples of the kind of money that is
available to us if we're willing to get
a little bit creative with how we
structure these insider deals and if
you're really serious about building the
side income as a public servant you
should probably check out some of the
other proxy schemes out there and there
are many of them there senator Mitch
McConnell and his wife profiting from
the Chinese government there's penny
Pritzker who's part of the family that
owns the Hyatt Hotel Empire who was
basically a mini Donald Trump serving as
Secretary of Commerce
she profited from her company's leasing
their buildings to the government while
in office and of course there's the all
money Donald Trump who came into office
with arguably the most business
connections with a business empire that
spans the entire globe but if you take
anything away from this video it should
be this with all these legal running
rounds at our disposal taking the wreck
bribes seem so Elementary so childish
why would you even need to consider
breaking the law anymore
these legal forms of corruption are
known as honest graft in S George
Washington Plunkett a man who helped run
the very corrupt Tammany Hall back in
the day in New York families he said
there is so much honest graft in this
town that they would be fools to go in
for the dishonest graft so don't be
fools learn the game and take what's
rightfully yours you want to know what's
also rightfully yours the two free
stocks weeble is giving you when you
open an account and deposit any amounts
when you open an account you'll get a
free stock value between two dollars and
fifty cents to two hundred fifty dollars
and when you deposit any amounts you'll
get another one value at twelve dollars
to fourteen hundred dollars and to make
matters even better right now at the
time of recording this not investing
advice this happens to be one of those
rare moments that only come once every
few years too few decades where the
market has a massive drop and almost
everything is on sale
and you can take advantage of this rare
opportunity using your corrupt profits
of course with one of the best free
trading apps that has the perfect
balance between ease of use and having
all the tools you need
funny story I usually use one of those
other popular free trading apps and
during one of the times the market
dropped recently that app was down for
everyone and when everyone was panicking
and trying to sell and I was trying to
buy in that is when I switched the
Weeble and have been using it ever since
so join the ranks of high-level
investors like Warren Buffett and buy
when they're severe when stocks go down
it's good news just like what hamburgers
get out it's good news they're coca-cola
this is how it is good news it turns and
cleaner to free stocks by clicking the
link in the video description
do you like unethical ways to make money
while you're sure gonna like this
channel because every single week we go
over the most provocative stuff in the
world of business so if you like this
video click the subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell because
it's free and you can dislike and unsub
whenever you want if you want to support
this channel financially claim your two
free stocks already with the link below
these sponsors really do help make this
channel possible you can follow me on
instagram at jake trend ah io that's
gonna wrap it up for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one God's availing have been
my lovers near Lord let this moment last
for another year though today has ended
the night's still young I'd say don't go
a